If you ever get the chance to visit a traditional Chinese home,...
...here are a few things you'll want to know and remember.
Most Chinese people are happy to have guests visit their homes.
You can bring a gift if you'd like.
A good gift might be something like fruit or some kind of drink.
You also might be offered slippers to wear while you're visiting.
Remember to remove your shoes when entering the home.
It's good manners and shows respect.
Either you'll use slippers while you're visiting or you'll walk around in socks.
It's important to most Chinese to be on time.
If you are invited somewhere, don't be late.
Showing up on time is respectful to other people.
This is more important in big cities than it is in the countryside.
Lastly, the Chinese generally don't make compliments.
When visitors compliment something, the Chinese will often say the opposite.
If you say a young girl is cute, they might be embarrassed about the compliment.
If you say a meal is good, they might say something didn't turn out right.